hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today I'm
gonna explain a 2017 Japanese fantasy
and science fiction movie called
Fullmetal Alchemist adapted from a
renowned manga series of the same name
the movie begins with two brothers Ed
and Al and their mother Trisha living a
normal life in resemble
the brothers self-learn Alchemy and
happily showcase their abilities to
Trisha unfortunately she dies due to
illness at her grave the brothers talk
about homunculi artificial humans
created by Alchemy and wonder if they
can bring Trisha back using their
Alchemy skills even though it is
considered taboo
sometimes later they find the way to
bring back their mother by human
transmutation they gather all of the
materials needed and then perform the
ritual to bring her back but it goes
wrong not as expected Alice Carried Away
by the storm surrounding them and is
severely injured years later in real Ed
chases an old man seemingly carrying a
philosopher's stone the man puts up a
fight by utilizing the Stone's powers to
awaken stone giants and manipulate
matters to hurt Ed but Ed insists on
getting the stone he performs Alchemy or
transmuting without a circle which
amazes the old man Ed summons a giant
Spear and skillfully defeats the stone
giants Al now a man in a hollow armor
suit joins him the old man recognizes
them as Fullmetal Alchemist Brothers
then runs to a more crowded part of the
town and threatens a girl's life Ed and
I'll fight him until his Stone breaks
off but it is taken by Colonel Roy
Mustang the fire Alchemist he burns the
stone proving it to be a fake since a
real Philosopher's Stone will not break
he instructs his men to take Ed to his
City headquarters while all stays behind
to repair the damage caused by the fight
unbeknownst to them a group of
mysterious people in Black clothing are
secretly watching them while Al repairs
the town and interacts with its people
his longtime friend winry shows up and
greets him in East City headquarters
where Colonel Mustang questions add Ed
states that he is determined to find the
real Philosopher's Stone to retrieve
Al's Body despite State military's rules
that forbid performing Alchemy on humans
Ed's friend Captain Hughes suddenly
walks in and introduces him to a
superior General hakuro who is eager to
meet the brothers later when they walk
together Hughes and Ed meet Winery who
is surprised to see Ed's broken Auto
male prosthetic limb meanwhile General
hakuru tells Colonel Mustang that he
wants the brothers to be introduced to
Tucker who may Aid them in their quest
to find the Philosopher's Stone back in
real the old man carrying a fake
Philosopher's Stone turns out to be
working for the mysterious group of
people consisting of lust envy and
gluttony they seem to possess inhuman
abilities and murder the old man
meanwhile Ed Al and winry are invited to
dinner at Captain Hughes house and are
warmly welcomed by his pregnant wife
Gracia Hughes even allow them to stay
overnight while sleeping Ed experiences
a nightmare a reenactment of the
disaster he and L caused when trying to
bring back their mother turns out the
disaster cost Al's Soul then Ed is
transported to another worldly place
called the Gate of Truth guarded by
truth a form of mysterious being based
on the Alchemy rule of law of equivalent
exchange Ed must trade something in
exchange for him to learn about human
transmutation in which he traded one of
his legs learning that Al's soul is also
compromised he traded his right arm for
Al's soul and binds it to a suit of
armor he wakes up with Al by his side
knowing that his brother has the same
nightmare again the next day the
brothers are escorted to meet Shu Tucker
the sowing life Alchemist who
successfully transmuted a talking
Chimera two years ago the Chimera only
spoke three words and then died while Ed
and tucked have a serious talk Al and
winry play with Tucker's daughter and
dog Nina and Alexander Tucker learns
about Ed's sacrifice his attempt at
human transmutation and his quest for
the Philosopher's Stone Tucker also
explains that his evaluation as a state
Alchemist is coming and he is stressed
out by its preparation though he is not
sure of the Stone's existence He
suggests Ed see a missing Stone
researcher named Dr Marco last located
in Barnes Ed and Winery leave while all
stays behind to be examined by Tucker
during the train ride to Barnes Ed and
winry are enjoying gracia's apple pie
while Winery suddenly notices a man
resembling Dr Marco she quickly jumps
off the train even though they are not
yet at Barnes then chases after the man
Marco attempts to attack them thinking
that the military is after him however
he stopped attacking soon after and
warns Ed to not chase after the stone
even though he is determined to find it
they are surprised by lust who appears
from behind and skillfully attacks Marco
lust attacks Ed and Winery too but
decides to spare their lives then
quickly disappears in his last breaths
Dr Marco gives Ed a stone to transmute
the Philosopher's Stone and says that he
can find it in lab number five Ed
quickly heads back to Tucker's residence
while winry stays behind to report
Marco's assassination to the military
while Ed and winry are away Tucker
examines how Al cannot feel pain and is
unsure whether the talking suit of armor
is actually Al's Soul he thinks it is a
soul implanted with false memories
believing it to be Al since he
underestimated Ed's capability to
perform transmutation on the human soul
when Ed arrives back at Tucker's he
notices the house feels empty with Nina
and Alexander nowhere to be seen he
meets exhausted Tucker who finally
completed his experiment of talking
Chimera Ed notices the talking Chimera
resembles Alexander while uttering
Nina's words then deduces the Tucker
experimented on Nina and Alexander's
lives Tucker claims that he is no
different than Ed playing with human
lives for their experiments Ed beats him
up and reports his unethical experiment
to the military causing him to be
arrested
he then locks himself up in the library
for three days straight to find more
information about the stone based on
Marco's clues Captain Hughes and
Lieutenant Ross assist him deducing that
they might be unraveling a big mystery
in the military related to Marco's
assassination and the appearance of lust
and her mysterious group suddenly
General hakura walks in and tells them
that the lab number five they are
looking for is an abandoned Cannery Ed
quickly heads there then another
military officer walks in to report
about riots in Rio Hughes is eager to
deal with the situation but the general
tells him there is nothing to worry
about Ed Al and win research the whole
Cannery to find nothing Al begins to
question if the stone and his body
really exist he assumes he is given a
false memory remembering Tucker's words
the brothers then fight winry stands up
for Ed telling Al that Ed's sacrifice so
much for him meanwhile Hughes deciphers
the location of the riots and their
connection to the locations of the
military lap he deduces the actual
location of lab number five but then
lust sneaks from behind and attacks him
he throws a dagger at her and runs away
to a telephone box contacting Colonel
Mustang to report that the military is
compromised however Colonel Mustang
appears from behind and seemingly shoots
Hughes dead a troop suddenly comes to
the Cannery and escorts Ed to
headquarters where he is treated like a
criminal from Mustang's Lieutenant
Hawkeye Ed learns that Hughes was
murdered by Mustang and now his comrades
are being watched or detained by the
military Mustang also let Tucker out
which puts Al in danger Ed determines to
break free and find the actual lab
number five which is an unused prisoner
of war camp Lieutenant Ross has been
waiting for Mustang there with a troop
of soldiers Mustang uses his Alchemy to
burn Ross alive surprising the whole
Troop turns out Ross comes back alive
and is actually Envy impersonating her
Mustang knows she is not the real Ross
by her misplaced mole lust and gluttony
come in to join Envy Mustang identifies
their uriburo tattoos telling Ed that
they are the homunculi artificial humans
created by Alchemy who possess
superpowers they learn Envy poses as
Mustang and Frames him for Hugh's murder
and Tucker's release
gluttony attacks the remaining troops
while lust fatally injures Mustang
unable to move further Mustang instructs
Ed to go after the homunculi and defeat
them Ed runs inside the camp to find
Tucker holding Alan Winery hostage he
learns about the Stone's true secret it
is transmuted using human Souls
sacrificing the Camp's prisoners lives
Tucker aims to shoot Ed but he is
stabbed from the back by lust
she then reveals herself to be working
for General hakuro he aims to transmute
artificial soldiers using the
Philosopher's stones and rule the world
but the newly awakened soldiers end up
chasing after him Ed Al winry Mustang
Hawkeye and the homunculi use their own
abilities to defeat the artificial Army
then Ed and Mustang go after lust and
envy lust tells them the homunculi
cannot be killed since they are created
by a philosopher's stone acting as their
hearts that grants them healing
abilities however Mustang mercilessly
Burns Envy multiple times until he seems
to heal longer than expected Mustang and
Ed deduced that the homunculi have a
limited number of regenerations before
they can finally be killed Mustang
continues attacking Envy by his fire
until he is defeated while Ed defends
himself from lusts attacks that mainly
come from her fingers Al arrives to help
protect Ed and conjures an earth wall
that cuts through lust's fingers
exposing her soft spot allowing Colonel
Mustang to defeat her and takes her
Philosopher's Stone he gives it to Ed
completing the brother's Quest Ed goes
back to the gate of truth truth assumes
Ed wants to trade the stone for Al's
Body which appears as tall and skinny
however Ed refuses the offer
acknowledging the Stone's human
sacrifice and not intending to use it he
promises Al that he will find another
way to retrieve his body coming back to
the human world Ed Embraces Al who also
agrees to stay in his current form and
not sacrifice human lives to retrieve
his body and also thanks Mustang and
encourages him to expose the truth
behind the military scheme
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching